ever wondered how rice a staple food for
many is harvested today we're diving
into the compelling world of rice
harvesting this process which has been
honed over centuries is of immense
importance worldwide it's a journey that
begins in verdant fields and ends in
your dinner plate rice harvesting
methods have evolved considerably over
time in many parts of the world
traditional manual methods still hold
sway where Farmers wield sharp sickles
to cut rice stalks under the baking sun
yet in other regions modern mechanized
methods have taken root with machines
efficiently reaping threshing and
winnowing the grain but whether it's
harvested by hand or machine each grain
of rice embodies the same labor of love
and dedication each tiny kernel
represents a story of growth resilience
and transformation in this video we
demystify the fascinating process of
rice harvesting taking you through each
step in detail so let's embark on this
journey together Unlocking The Wonder of
rice harvesting the first step in
harvesting rice is knowing when the crop
is ready it's all about timing when it
comes to Rice harvesting the process
begins when the rice plant exhibits
certain telltale signs of maturity the
first and most visible indication is a
change in color as the grains ripen the
vibrant green of the rice field
transforms into a sea of golden yellow
this color shift is a clear signal that
the grains are nearing Readiness next we
look at the grains themselves they
undergo a transformation as they mature
hardening from a soft milky texture to a
firm solid state when the grains Reach
This hardened stage it's another
indication that Harvest time is Drawing
Near however it's not just about
spotting these signs it's also about
understanding why timing matters so much
harvesting too early can result in
grains that are underdeveloped and
lacking in nutritional value on the
other hand if you wait too long you risk
the grains shattering and falling to the
ground leading to significant grain loss
to maximize yield it's important to
strike that perfect balance harvesting
when the majority of grains have reached
their Peak maturity this is where the
Art and Science of farming come together
where a Keen Eye and years of experience
play a crucial role in essence knowing
when to harvest is not just the first
step but also one of the most critical
steps in the rice harvesting process
harvesting at the right time is crucial
to the success of the crop once the rice
is ready to harvest the next step is
cutting the rice stocks this step is
crucial as it marks the transition of
the rice grains from the field to the
storage where they will be processed for
consumption there are two primary
methods for cutting rice manual and
mechanized the method used often depends
on the scale of the farm and the
available resources let's delve into
each of these methods to better
understand them first we have manual
cutting this method is often employed in
smaller Farms or in regions where Modern
Machinery is not readily available or
economical manual cutting involves the
use of a traditional hand tool known as
a sickle this curved blade is swung with
a practiced hand slicing through the
rice stalks near their base it's a labor
intensive process requiring strength and
endurance but it's also a method steeped
in Tradition connecting the farmer to
the Earth in a very tangible way on the
other end of the spectrum we have
mechanized cutting this method is
commonly used in larger scale farming
operations where efficiency and speed
are Paramount here a machine known as a
combine harvester is used used the
combine harvester is a Marvel of modern
technology it cuts threshes and
separates the rice grains from the
stocks in one Fell Swoop this method
significantly reduces the labor and time
required to harvest rice regardless of
the method used the result is the same
the rice stocks heavy with grains are
cut from the field the cut stalks known
as sheaves are then bundled together
these bundles serve a dual purpose they
make transport easier and they also
allow the rice to dry dry in is an
essential step in the rice harvesting
process as it reduces the moisture
content of the grain making it suitable
for storage and further processing so
whether it's a sickle in the hand of a
skilled farmer or the rumble of a
combine harvester The Cutting process is
a vital step in bringing rice from the
field to our tables after cutting the
rice is bundled and left to dry after
the rice stocks are cut and dried they
undergo threshing and winnowing these
are two crucial steps in the rice
harvesting process where we transition
from stocks to grains so let's delve
into what exactly these steps entail
first up is threshing threshing is the
process of separating the grains from
the stalks traditionally this was done
manually with Farmers using a flail a
simple tool consisting of two pieces of
wood connected by a short chain or
leather thong the stocks of rice would
be spread out on a flat surface and the
flail would be swung down onto them
breaking the grains free from the stalks
in today's modern age machines have
largely replaced manual labor and
threshing is no exception a mechanized
thresher works on the same principle but
does the job much faster and more
efficiently the cut stalks are fed into
the machine which beats or rubs them to
separate the grains now let's move on to
winnowing winnowing is the process of
separating the rice grains from the
chaff the husks that surround each grain
in the past Farmers would toss the
threshed grains into the air and the
wind would blow away the lighter chaff
while the heavier grains would fall back
down again modern technology has made
this process quicker and more efficient
a machine called a wiow essentially does
the same thing but in a controlled
environment the threshed grains are fed
into the Wier which uses a fan to blow
away the chaff leaving just the grains
so through the processes of threshing
and winnowing we separate the grains
from the stalks and the chaff getting us
one step closer to that bowl of rice
these steps have been integral parts of
rice harvesting for centuries and
although the methods have evolved the
principles Remain the the same at this
point we have our harvested rice but
it's not quite ready to eat yet the
final steps in the rice harvesting
process are milling and polishing now
let's dive into the details Milling is a
crucial step that transforms the
harvested Patty into edible rice this
process involves removing the outer husk
or Hull from the rice grain the husk is
tough and inedible but it protects the
grain during growth so it's served its
purpose by the time we get to Milling to
achieve this machines known as hullers
or Huskers are used these machines apply
mechanical force to the Patty either
through abrasion or through more direct
means like impacting or shearing the
result the husk is effectively removed
revealing the grain or what we call
brown rice but we're not done yet though
brown rice is perfectly edible most
people prefer their rice white and
that's where polishing comes in
polishing is the process of removing the
brand layer from the brown rice this
brand layer which is a thin coating over
the grain gives the rice its brown color
it's filled with nutrients but also has
a distinct taste that not everyone
enjoys to remove this layer the rice
goes through a machine called a polisher
this machine uses friction to gently rub
off the bran layer without damaging the
grain underneath the rice is often
sprayed with water during this process
to prevent overheating and to help
remove any remaining bran what emerges
from the other end of the polisher is
the white rice that we're all familiar
with it's clean shiny and ready to be
cooked into a delightful meal both
milling and polishing are carefully
controlled processes they need to be
done just right to ensure that the rice
is not damaged and that it retains its
nutritional value and there you have it
from field to table that's how rice is
harvested so let's recap the Journey of
rice from the field to your plate it all
starts with knowing when the rice is
ready to harvest this crucial stage
requires a Keen Eye and a deep
understanding of the rice plant's life
cycle harvesting too early or too late
can greatly affect the quality and yield
of the crop the next step is cutting the
rice this involves using either
traditional methods like a sickle or
Modern Machinery depending on the scale
of the operation the cut stalks are then
bundled and left to dry which allows the
grains to harden and reduces the
moisture content making the next steps
easier once dry the rice undergoes
threshing and winnowing threshing
separates the grain from the stalk while
winnowing removes the chaff from the
grain these processes are vital in
ensuring that only the pure grain makes
it to the next step the final steps are
milling and polishing Milling removes
the outer husk and brand layers from the
grain while polishing gives it that
distinctive shine these steps transform
the raw grain into the rice we recognize
on our plates each of these steps is
essential in ensuring a successful rice
Harvest they require a blend of
traditional knowledge modern techniques
and a lot of hard work next time you
enjoy a bowl of rice you'll know the
hard work and intricate process that
went into harvesting it